hey everyone i am here with neil
degrasse tyson renowned astrophysicist
and host of uh the popular star talk
um and you know we're here on the
occasion of
um
just these fantastic images that have
been taken by the james webb telescope
of of our universe and you know i'm
really focused on the metaverse and one
of the things that that i'm really
focused on here is how this is going to
help shape education over time so we
have some awesome stuff to show and i'm
really excited to be here with neil to
go through all of this because he's he's
kind of the the leading figure to help
explain all of this but first neil do
you want to just talk for a bit about
what's going on with the james webb
telescope and where it is and and and
basically set the stage here i would
love to set the stage so the james webb
telescope has been sort of on the
drawing boards for decades there were
early meetings where we said after
hubble where are we going to take our
understanding of the universe and we
knew that there was this gap in our
access to the universe in the earliest
times right after a period that we call
the dark ages while we're the universe
right after the big bang where the
universe had matter and energy but it
wasn't making anything yet no luminous
stars yet and so we call that the dark
ages and at the end of that dark ages
things start kicking in stars start
getting made galaxies start being born
and we didn't have any data from that
period so people said let's design a
telescope to do that can't do it from
earth's surface and even if we orbit the
earth that's not good enough we've got
to find a special place to park this
telescope and so
out of this came a place it's called one
of the lagrangian points of the earth
moon
orbiting system it's a place where all
the forces of gravity balance
and it's a million miles from earth
opposite the direction of the sun
and if you park something there it'll
stay and orbit the sun with the earth
now here's the catch this telescope is
specifically tuned to observe infrared
light
because that's the light that reaches us
from these newly born galaxies from 14
13 billion years ago
so but if you're going to observe
infrared which is a heat source okay
heat gives you
infrared your telescope has to be really
really cold
otherwise the telescope will observe
itself
okay so if so whatever you're observing
you got to make sure your telescope is
not interfering so you put it a million
miles away from earth and put a series
of sun shades
between it and the sun and it can
forever look out into the universe and
plunge to a very cold temperature all of
this happened uh in the pa in the design
and understanding of what this telescope
would bring i have to give a shout out
to the engineers to help make this
happen all right all the press is coming
to we scientists to talk about the cool
science but part the curtains their
engineers who scratch their head had to
figure out how how do you launch such a
thing and as big as this telescope is
it's got to fit inside of a rocket all
right the fairing of a rocket is not the
size of the telescope so they have to
find a way to fold the telescope so that
it can stuff it into a fairing put it a
million miles away open the fairing and
unfurl the all the detectors and
the and the sun shades so it is a marvel
of engineering and i'm delighted to be
able to share the fruits of that
engineering with you and all of your
audience
awesome so we have a bunch of things in
virtual reality to look at including
some 3d images from the telescope and
some videos of spacewalks and some
awesome things that that that we can
check out and feel like we're really
there so do you want to just jump into
vr
let's do that
do i how do you is there something you
say like i meet you on the other side or
something is this i guess we'll i'll see
you in space in a minute you know so
mark that that's me
i got a picture of me
yeah there you go and and
and the telescope it gives you a real
sense of scale for the thing yeah so i
was at a conference a space conference
in colorado springs colorado of course
and northrop grumman who is the sort of
the the engineering partner with nasa
brought this scale model of the
telescope
to the conference and i said i gotta
stand in front of this thing and so
there it is the actual telescope uh you
see people in a clean room uh putting in
the last touches i want you to notice
that there's this strut
that goes across it
that strut is actually responsible for
diffracting starlight that gives the
starlight those spikes you might you
will see in a later photo so hang on for
that so this whole thing folds up
into
the fairing
of
a rocket and like i said it's an
engineering marvel that we could get
this to happen at all we knew we
couldn't use a single mirror because the
single mirror doesn't give you that
latitude so you make a honeycomb mirror
and the hexagonal shape is one of only
three shapes that you can tile a floor
with the square the triangle and a
hexagon and so you do hexagons and
that's our mirror and each one is
separately controlled and then there you
have it
nice
oh right so so what are we looking at
here oh
okay so the spiky things that sort of
resemble like the star of bethlehem uh
those are stars sitting right on our
noses
here in our own milky way galaxy and
those like i said those spikes come from
the hardware that's within the telescope
so just ignore the stars for now there's
about a half dozen in this image big one
right in the upper left three across the
bottom one on the side and some and you
can see some others off to the thing so
what's going on here is we have the
deepest image ever taken of the universe
and notice a bunch of everything else
that's not those spiky things is an
entire galaxy such as the milky way
containing hundreds of billions of stars
and we see them out to the farthest
reaches of the universe and you see
these arklets that form a circle around
the central region there's a galaxy
cluster right in the middle which has a
huge gravitational field and those those
curved arklets are are galaxies in the
background
near the beginning of the universe and
their light has been distorted by the
gravitational field of this cluster and
einstein first described the fact that
if you have a lot of gravity it'll
distort the very fabric of the
space-time continuum so this is direct
evidence of that what are kind of the
smudges between the galaxies for example
if you look at the arc over there uh-huh
uh-huh every single smudge in this image
that does not have spikes
is a distant galaxy just like our own
the galaxy catalog has all kinds of
objects all kinds of shapes and sizes
there's spiral galaxies elliptical
galaxies we have distorted irregular
galaxies their dwarf galaxies they have
all different shapes and sizes and they
are different colors depending on what
stage of evolution their stars are in
and so here you have this zoo of
galaxies in an area on the sky
no bigger than a grain of sand held at
arm's length
so you ask yourself how much of the sky
does a grain of sand cover at arm's
length
take a picture that this is what you get
this is our universe
in all its majesty
brought to you
by the james webb space telescope
oh yes and so now yeah this is i'm
loving this one so again this is the
iconic photo oh yes this one people love
in this one so the james webb space
telescope is specially tuned to observe
the universe using infrared light
because the most distant galaxies by the
time their light reaches us it's in the
infrared part of the spectrum so the
telescope was conceived and designed to
do that
but wait
infrared light also penetrates nearby
gas clouds and so this is the carina
nebula and you're seeing into a nebula
that you would not otherwise have access
to if we looked at this with visible
light it would just be this big cloud
and be nothing there and now you can
look in and see stars and there are
places where stars are being born this
is a stellar nursery stars are made of
gas these are where does that gas come
from it comes from gas clouds and so
curiously the james webb space telescope
has data from the beginning of the
universe
and from nearby places that are the
beginning of stars themselves and these
stars will not only make star clusters
but also planets and possibly even
people
probably not other life forms we only
have people on earth we're pretty sure
but again you see the spiky other stars
these are nearby objects that are giving
us those spikes but this is this this
whole image is nearby this is a
relatively nearby region of the
formation of stars within our galaxy
and so what has this all told us about
the universe that we didn't already know
the good thing about the james webb
space telescope is that it's
it's opening a window to the universe
that we didn't previously previously
have access to so in the early universe
no telescope had ever seen there before
deep in these gas clouds no telescope
had ever seen that before and so you can
make the list of what you expect to find
of course
based on any prior knowledge but anytime
you open a window you've got to be ready
to discover things that nobody ordered
that nobody asked for that nobody even
thought to wonder was there
so for me the future of the the james
webb space telescope is not what
questions it can answer that we've
already posed it's what questions it
will answer that we don't yet know to
ask
yeah i mean this is this i think has
really captured people's imagination has
been been awesome all right so what are
we looking at here
okay so now there are galaxies in the
universe that are nearby other galaxies
they feel each other's gravity and they
and they fall towards one another and
interact and that's the polite way to
say it what they're really doing is
colliding this is called stefan's
quintet there are five galaxies here one
of them is not really had not joined the
party the one in the bottom the other
four
are actively colliding with each other
and when you collide gas clouds smash
into each other and they form stars when
that happens it sends shock waves
through what we call the interstellar
medium and it so curiously the collision
of galaxies is also the birth of stars
and you see these regions these these
these spots
the all the the the red regions where
you have active star formation going on
it's called stefan's quintet and when i
saw this back when i was in graduate
school many moons ago it's just
five five smudges on the sky you can't
get inside and see what's going on with
this resolution so the telescope is
bringing things that were previously
hidden in plain sight
to the front
and it now enables us to ask new
questions uh understand in great detail
what goes on when when galaxies collide
by the way our own milky way is on a
collision course with the andromeda
galaxy two million light years away and
we'll collide in about six or seven
billion years i have it on my calendar
so
i'm gonna watch for that
but it's a train wreck when it happened
these are still recognizable as discrete
objects give this a few more years a few
more millions of years as they start
moving through each other and greatly
disrupting their structure and you're
gonna end up with uh what is basically a
train wreck and but a new kind of galaxy
the sum of all of these galaxies and as
far as we know every major galaxy has a
black hole in its center and so you can
ask when galaxies collides what happens
to their
through their black holes all right we
based on
computer simulations we know the black
holes find each other and collide and
you know how we know they collide
because we see them with a whole other
telescope the the laser interferometer
gravitational wave observatory and
that's ligo and we saw data from that so
all of the telescopes that we have on
earth and in the heavens come together
to give us a coherent picture of our
place in the universe
this is pretty wild it's totally and
once again we see the spiky stars that
are just sitting in front of us now okay
where do i begin
all right so every red-blooded star
is going to
die like this okay the sun when it dies
it's going to look something like this
so now we're on a much
it's a bigger image but it's a smaller
scale
this is the gas
sloped off
in the dying stages of a star and the
the bit of light you see in the middle
is that sort of a left over star once
it's given up its outer layers and this
is called the southern ring nebula
there's a ring nebula in the north which
is called the ring nebula
without modification
but in this image you're seeing
different layers of the sun
that it got so big in its later stages
they become red giant stars become so
big the gases just keep floating into
space and they get charged they get they
get illuminated by the very hot center
that's still there in the middle of the
star so
to bask in the majesty of this object in
the universe not just looking at it on a
small postage stamp on a or even on a
computer screen i mean i'm in this it's
like i'm in a space station parked
outside of this celestial object so it
feels very very real
that's what you're after here and i
happen to know that the energy being
emitted by that star in the middle is
actually quite hostile to human
physiology it's very high in ultraviolet
light which would be bad for you so you
would need filters and things and and uh
if you're gonna if you want to be a
tourist of the universe have like
different levels of sunscreen available
to you in the cabinet so that you can
get close to stuff that might otherwise
fry your dna
the s f 2000 yeah or more
you got that you got that i wear it from
time to time yeah yeah
we're we're in space this is this is a
spacewalk and i do before we just jump
into talking about what's going on here
i just want to
give um one quick plug that we're going
to be working with nasa to live stream
um in vr
the launch of of the uh of the new
artemis so can you explain like what
what are we looking at
all right so we're floating here so
we're doing our own space walking okay
what i love here is can you see these
long
uh gold uh strips these are unfurled
these are solar panels and they're
unfurled all right because again you
have to launch them somehow
there's not a rocket that size so you
curl them up and then they get unfurled
back when they come back into space and
we see some of our fellow astronauts
there all right and
they're they look like they're doing
something busy when we're just sort of
observing them
and of course when you are weightless
there is no up or down so you can say
well isn't earth down not when you're
weightless
we are weightless right now and most
people think just the act of being in
space makes you weightless that is false
that's just completely false what's
going on is
this
entire
structure everything and the astronauts
everything is falling towards the earth
you say kalham is not going to hit the
earth because it's all saying we wave to
the astronauts uh we go
we're also moving sideways at five miles
per second
you ever see the rocket launch it goes
up but then wait it goes down down you
know it goes downstream
so much of the energy is just to give it
the speed why because it goes so far
downrange
at the speed of five miles per second
that for every foot it falls
the curvature of the earth
curves a foot away from it so the point
is we are falling towards the earth at
the same rate that earth's curved
surface is curving away from us and so
everybody is in free fall
everything at all times but now we get
to look towards earth
it really feels like we're falling you
know what's good about these images if
you do it late in the day for earth
then you get shadows cast by uneven
textures on the cloud tops and so they
become much more real when that happened
to see how long the shadows are on those
clouds that are up there yeah and they
get to see storm systems brewing very uh
unstable air rising up ready to make
thunderstorms and so right now we're
transitioning out of daylight into earth
darkness and at that speed of five miles
per second 18 17 18 000 miles an hour at
that speed
you orbit the earth you see 18 sunrises
and sunsets a day
18 a day
and i'm loving it
and there it is all right well that was
pretty darkness yeah should we head back
to our space station yeah let's do that
let's do that all right you know what
you think of this whole experience it's
clearly ready for prime time we have
visual data
on the universe and probably in other
sciences they have enough information
about the structure of cells that any
place you hadn't gone before
because you
you couldn't or you just would read
about it if you get to go inside and i
don't see why that wouldn't be the next
best thing
uh to do with your curiosity
yeah i mean i'm really interested in the
kind of where this helps take education
i mean we're already seeing you know
doctors being trained for surgeries
doing it more effectively when they can
actually just see a big model of a knee
that they're going to operate on for
example and i just think this is gonna
give people way more opportunities yeah
i think the the applications are
limitless clearly
awesome all right well this has been
super fun thank you for for doing this
okay mark it's great great to meet you
and and in fact that one day maybe we'll
get you on my podcast and we'll talk
about yeah i'd love to do it your vision
of the future because you're one of the
one of the shakers and movers of where
society is going to go
in ways people to dream
i would love to do that i'm a huge fan
of your work and everything you've done
and how you inspire so many people about
the wonder of the universe so it's it's
awesome stuff and it's really awesome
for for me to get a chance to do this
with you so yeah chris bomb
there you go
good you got it all right dude all right
see ya